the equations below all define the same
polynomial function f of x so they just
written f of x in different ways here
they fully factored f of x out as
negative four times x minus three times
x minus two times x plus one times x
plus five then here this is actually it
looks like they factored it once and
then they factored into two quadratics
and then they completed the square for
each of those quadratics and then here
this is just factoring it into two
quadratic expressions and then here this
is the thing just fully expanded out
multiplied out as a polynomial
which of the file which of which of
which form of f of x is most useful for
determining end behavior
so when we think about end behavior we
really want to focus on the highest
degree term we really want to focus on
this term right over here because as x
becomes very very very positive this
term is going to dominate and as x
becomes very very very negative this
term is going to dominate and so this
term is really going to describe what
the end behavior is and we can even
think about the end behavior here we
have a even exponent so it's going to
have behavior like x squared which is
just another way of saying that as x
gets positive the function is going to
get positive very positive and as x
becomes very negative the function is
going to become very positive because
it's an even exponent and the fact that
there's a negative coefficient in front
front of this highest degree
the highest degree x term this tells us
it's going to be similar to the shape of
negative x squared it's going to be
downward opening if you were to think
about its end behavior so which form of
the function is most useful well
definitely d the expanded out version
so i'll go with d
select the equation below its similar
end behavior f of x well we already
talked about it it's an even
it's an even exponent or it's an even
degree we could say and we have a
negative out in front of it so it's
going to be it's going to have similar
end behavior to y is equal to negative x
squared and then they say which form of
f of x is most useful for finding zeros
well when we're finding zeros we're
trying to find the x values that would
make the function equal to zero and this
first form right over here where we're
all factored out that's the most useful
for finding zeros we know that if the if
we wanted to set this whole thing to be
equal to zero we said hey when does this
equal zero that means that one of these
expressions at least one of these
expressions need to be equal zero we can
independently set them equal to zero and
then solve for x so this would be zero
when x is equal to three x is equal to
two x is negative one and x is negative
five so a is definitely the most useful
the most useful for finding zeros